el presidente del comité olímpico
internacional Thomas Bach ha rechazado
la actitud de los gobiernos que se han
pronunciado en contra de su
recomendación de readmitir atletas rusos
y bielorrusos en eventos deportivos
escuchemos
es deplorable que estos gobiernos no
aborden la cuestión del doble rasero con
el que nos han enfrentado en nuestras
consultas
no hemos visto un solo comentario de
ellos sobre su actitud hacia la
participación de atletas cuyos países
están involucrados en las otras 70
guerras y conflictos armados en el mundo
para analizar este tema nos acompaña en
nuestro estudio en Bogotá la periodista
especializada en deportes eumar esa
eumar bienvenida Gracias por estar con
nosotros y usted qué tanto sabe de
Juegos Olímpicos cuéntenos Cuáles son
las condiciones para admitir el retorno
de estos deportistas en principio los
atletas deben participar bajo bandera
neutral la apertura no se extiende a
deportes de Conjunto y el veto se
mantiene para los deportistas con
vínculos militares en momento el comité
olímpico internacional no se ha
pronunciado sobre la participación en
los juegos de París 2024 un tema que
según Back Todavía no se ha discutido
aquí hay que mencionar que muchos
atletas rusos al ser convocados a
selecciones nacionales obtienen algún
tipo de grado militar de hecho el
Ministerio de defensa ruso ha dicho que
al menos 20 de sus medallistas en Tokio
2020 eran parte del ejército y cómo ha
reaccionado el mundo del deporte
probablemente la reacción más violenta
Se ha producido Precisamente en el
deporte de Vázquez la esgrima donde se
han cancelado hasta ahora dos torneos
satélites en Suecia y en Finlandia y una
copa del mundo en Alemania como una
forma de retrasar la participación ya
autorizada en este deporte para rusos y
bielorrusos el gobierno polaco está
bloqueando al momento del ingreso de los
rusos al país para la copa del mundo de
floreste de posnam en el tenis que es el
deporte que ha citado como modelo de
inclusión la u
reveló hoy que Durante un año han
tratado sin éxito de bloquear la
participación Bueno pero la posición del
comité olímpico internacional antes era
distinta porque de hecho fueron los
primeros en recomendar el veto A qué se
debe Este cambio de postura precisamente
al involucramiento de los gobiernos al
que se refería bac que quiebra uno de
los principios fundamentales de la carta
olímpica la autonomía del deporte
recordemos por ejemplo el Beto en
wimbledon esa fue una recomendación del
Ministerio del deporte que asumió el
ente rector de estos torneos que es el
olinkland tenis Club ahora el Primer
Ministro polaco anunciado que se buscará
crear una coalición de países que
respalden a Polonia en el retiro de
selecciones de eventos internacionales
lo cual representa una Clara amenaza de
boicot algo que en el deporte no se
presentaba desde seúl 1988